hey guys today we're gonna talk about
low back pain alright I mean it can be
very irritating I'm going to show you
some great things you can do to actually
help yourself most back pain comes from
sitting way too long so sitting kills
your lower back alright
I'm just curious how many hours do you
sit on a given day go ahead and tell me
down below in the comments section
personally I sit way too long so what
happens when you're sitting or sitting
when you're driving is you basically
lose the lower back curvature normally
in your lower back
you need this curve that goes forward
when you lose the curve you create a lot
of compression on those disks and the
nerve roots and you creates attica and
you create which is pain down the leg
and you create muscle spasm and all
sorts of imbalances because you need
this curve to act as a cushion to
support your upper torso so when you
don't have the curve it creates a lot
more pressure on the disks same thing
happens with your neck as well you need
a curve in your neck now the techniques
I'm going to show you are basically six
and they involve a foam roller okay now
I couldn't really find the foam roller
that I wanted because for example like
this one it's too big alright it's good
if you put in your lower back it's gonna
it's gonna actually hurt and then what I
did is I got a softer one right it still
didn't work so then I got a little bit
smaller one but it's just too firm so
then I had a bright idea what I did is I
basically just cut this thing right in
half okay and this is what it looks like
right here very simple and the reason
that I like this shape is that the back
part stabilizes on a chair very very
nicely it doesn't slip around it kind of
sticks to the chair now you don't have
to get mine you can make your own you
can roll up a towel really tight but I'm
going to show you how to do these
procedures with this foam roller okay so
no one when they're sitting in a chair
sits up nice and tall they they kind of
slouch right here now if you look at my
lower back it's just it's rounded okay
so I'm losing the lower back curve now
there's several problems with this
number one my pelvis is constantly going
back this way and I'm losing the lower
back curve so it's actually reversing
the curve just as I'm sitting right here
not to mention
driving in my car the same deal I'm
always losing that curve okay or taking
a plane somewhere those chairs are
terrible
they're very cramped and they have no
support for your lower back okay so I'm
gonna show you the first thing you
basically put it right in your lower
back not at the very lower back but a
little bit higher up you know there's a
there's five lumbar vertebra and you
have your ribs that come off through
here so this you want this directly
underneath your ribs okay at the at like
l2 l1 area which is right about here so
you just kind of lean back and it puts
the curve right back really nicely it's
not too big where it's actually sitting
sitting out like this and it's just
really comfortable and it supports my
lower back alright the next thing you
want to do because you want to create
more motion if you're sitting all day
long just like this it's gonna be
uncomfortable as well because your body
needs to move around so I like to rotate
between this position right here and
this position right here I'm going to
take this thing and I'm gonna lay it
flat right on the chair right here and
I'm gonna sit back so my sacrum okay
which is that you're right in the back
part of your pelvis rocks forward okay
so I'm allowing this curve to very
gently push on my sacrum to rock forward
like here now my lower back curve is
actually going forward and it feels very
very relaxed and you'll notice when your
curve is forward all the muscles like
just melt
there's no tightness anymore so I'll do
this for a while and then I might go
back to this right here back and forth
another really good stretch you can do
and you just raise it up right here and
you can just lean back and stretch right
over certain pivot points so I'm gonna
take this right here and I'm gonna go a
little bit lower and I'm just gonna
stretch this is like t12 the thoracic
vertebra 12 I'm going to starts back
okay and I'm gonna go to t9 okay and the
stretch back through here okay
just kind of push up this way let's
stretch back and go all up my spine the
nice thing about this is it's kind of
sticks on the chair real nicely and I
can create a nice backward stretch
there's a lot of ligaments in the back
end muscles as well on the front part of
the vertebra there's a it's called the
anterior longitudinal ligament and with
gravity it tends to cause people to go
forward and kind of get stuck in this
posture right here so this tends to
reverse that posture and it gives you a
lot of relief and it just so happens a
lot of those nerve endings through the
mid-back are related to something called
the sympathetic nervous system that's
where it's located and so when you do
this it creates a lot of relaxation okay
so it feels really good so I'll actually
do the lower back right here okay which
is very very relaxing and I'll switch to
this right here back and forth of the
day okay I might do the other stretches
right here because I'd sit a long time
during the day doing my research kissed
our set but then what we do is we take
this on your butt bone it's called
ischial tuberosities there's two bones
that you sit on okay it's part of your
pelvis what you do is you just take this
right here and you you sit on it on one
side okay and what this is gonna do it's
gonna cause your pelvis to tilt to the
side this way to the to the left side
right here and you're gonna be
stretching all the muscles on the left
side the oblique muscles another muscle
called the quadratus lumborum
the so as all these muscles you're gonna
stretch to this side and this will allow
you to give your lower back some more
motion in symmetry now when you actually
stretch to this side and you compare it
to the other side you're gonna feel one
sides going to be tighter usually so I'm
going to do this side and what you want
to do is just take the tight side and
really work that more than the other
side and what you're doing is you're
just creating symmetry in your lower
back it gives your lower back a lot of
relief this is basically what I do
because I'm sitting a lot okay so we got
that the next stretch I'm going to show
you is you put this writer Neath your
hamstring okay right here so it raises
the leg up the femur
and then you lean forward and you can
stretch this way okay but what I like to
do is I like to to cross my leg and it's
all nice and raised and I like to kind
of get this a little bit higher up this
way and lean forward and really kind of
stretch the lower back the glutes and
the all the muscles in the lower back so
I create some space okay so stretching
that side as well as a little bit on the
hamstring and I'll take it on the left
side and again I'm comparing left to
right and I'm stretching the one that
needs to be stretched more it's it feels
really good when you do this because it
gives you a lot of relief in space so
I'll do that side right there okay so
just to recap lower back cushion right
here lay it flat back right here look
the little round part rock your pelvis
forward okay you could do the mid back
as well to reverse the the hunchback
that people are getting all the time
okay and then I'll do this it's called
the issue of tuberosity or just the butt
bone and I'll stretch it going you're
basically stretching the pelvis to one
side okay and you're feeling the
tightness comparing it to the other side
and I'm going to take the side that's
more tight and I'm going to take the
side that's more restricted and stretch
that more okay but it feels really
really good okay
alright now the next thing I'm gonna do
is going to take this thing right here
underneath my hamstring I'll start with
this side just to keep it okay and then
I'll cross my leg I lean forward so I'm
really taking the muscles in the in your
butt muscle was called gluttonous and
the back and I'm just stretching all
those muscles really nicely creating in
that space and this kind of will save
your lower back it keeps the curve in
the lower back
it keeps the back from getting stiff and
that way you can sit longer right you
can sit for eight eighteen hours instead
of eight hours but on a on a flight oh
my gosh this will save you when you're
flying long distances because it's so
uncomfortable sitting in those chairs
alright now the question is can use in
your car possibly it depends on how your
seat is positioned at the
wraps around you it might be more
difficult but if it's flat it would work
fine so you can try that alright and
there's one less stretch I'm going to
show you which basically involves just
stretching your your calves okay
and you're gonna basically stretch your
calf like this right here and why do you
want to stretch the calf well simply
because the lower back muscles are
connected to the hamstring which is
connected to the calf and if you stretch
this it creates more space okay so the
entire back could be stretched by
stretching your calf and we're just
going to do both sides right here and
that'll actually create more space
alright guys thanks for watching and go
ahead and try this out and let me know
through the comments section below how
it can help you and I'll see you in the
next video
hey guys real quick I have a new healthy
keto eating plan for you just go to dr.
Berg comm it's right on the front page I
put a link down below download it it's
free check it out